here's something that seems to have
somehow flown under the radar and this
is from politico i'm going to read this
to you and you tell me if anything jumps
out at you
there's anything here that raises a red
flag i don't know
um it says the buy administration is
casting conservative opponents of his
cove
of its cove 19 vaccine campaign as
dangerous and extreme
adopting a more aggressive political
posture in an attempt to maneuver
through the public health conundrum well
this is nothing new
it's not like this is a new strategy in
a new strategy liberals are
casting their opponents as dangerous
extremists
it's an interesting new strategy we'll
put we'll see if it pays off
but it continues the white house has
decided to hit back harder on
misinformation
quote unquote misinformation and scare
tactics after republican lawmakers and
conservative activists
pledge to fight the administration's
stated plans to go door to door to
increase vaccination rates
the pushback will include directly
calling out social media platforms and
conservative news shows that promote
such tactics
listen to this part biden allied groups
including
the democratic national committee are
also planning to engage
fact checkers more aggressively and work
with sms
carriers to dispel misinformation about
vaccines
that is sent over social media and text
messages
the goal is to ensure that people who
have who may have difficulty getting a
vaccination because of issues like
transportation
see those barriers lessened or removed
entirely
now i don't know call me crazy
but
it seems as though they're saying that
the dnc
is going to be colluding with fact
checkers to monitor our private text
messages
all in an effort to head off
misinformation you know it's for our own
good that's all
you got to understand that if the dnc
is checking in on your text messages
maybe your emails whatever
it's all for your own good if the nsa is
doing it's all for your own good
because there might be dangerous
extremists out there who are trying to
uh you know talk to you and and
convince you of things and you're too
stupid of course
just like i we're all too stupid to be
able to
practice discernment and that's why we
need big brother
who can swoop in and uh and save the day
now how is so i i saw this report in
politico
and then i was googling to see if
there's been other headlines about this
and there hasn't been anything
how is this not a big deal at least
that's the report that they're going to
be monitoring our private text messages
i guess you know if you have a problem
with it just start your own cell phone
carrier that's all
start your own verizon you don't like it
private company start your own verizon
[Music]
that i'm sure will be um the response
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated